un panorama tan extraordinario como
perturbador 270 ballenas piloto un tipo
delfín oceánico atrapadas en bancos de
arena elevados frente a la costa
occidental de tasmania intentar rescatar
las es una tarea titánica el gerente del
servicio de parques y vida silvestre del
estado explica que la prueba y error es
el único método posible para proceder
es en gran medida un proceso de tratar
de encontrar el mejor método así que
intentaremos liberar algunas ballenas
esta mañana y si tenemos éxito con el
método que hemos elegido seguiremos
haciéndolo si no lo adaptaremos y
haremos diferentes cosas para intentar
obtener un mejor resultado
y nadie sabe que atrajo los animales tan
cerca de la orilla se cree que al menos
un tercio de ellas han muerto la
prioridad ahora es centrarse en los que
tienen más probabilidades de sobrevivir
el trias va a ser bastante importante
aquí tenemos animales repartidos en un
área grande y en una ubicación realmente
desafiante así que básicamente vamos a
tomar a los animales con la mejor
oportunidad para empezar y los que somos
capaces de tratar al bund de wish los
encallamientos de ballenas aquí no son
inusuales pero la escala de este silo es
en tasmania el último a escala masiva se
registró en 2009 e involucró a unas 200
ballenas las autoridades dicen que la
operación de rescate podría demorar
varios días